wow
[Musica]
[Applauso]
no no
[Musica]
[Applauso]
immaginate di trovarvi in un'aula dello
sforzo war college negli stati uniti
assieme a un gruppo di studenti quando
il professor solo monash pone a tutti
uno specifico quesito
ora immaginate che mentre il resto del
gruppo dalla stessa risposta
voi siete convinti che questa sia
sbagliata
cosa fate
quello che successe realmente
durante il noto test di conformità
psicologica condotta dal professor ash
fu che il 75 per cento dei partecipanti
si conforma alla risposta del gruppo
nonostante fosse errata
era il
1950 e questo test ebbe il pregio di
aprire la strada nei decenni successivi
a una serie di importanti studi ed
evidenze sul grado di pressione sociale
esercitata dal gruppo sulle opinioni e
comportamenti dei singoli individui
ciò che ne risulta è che più ci colpisce
è che le persone si fanno influenzare
principalmente per due motivi
perché vogliono sentirsi parte
integrante di un gruppo e ne temono
giudizio oppure perché sono realmente
convinte che gli altri siano più e
meglio informati di loro
un terzo ed importante elemento è che
con la conformità si realizza la fusione
delle identità ovvero quando una persona
un singolo individuo si fonde con il
gruppo e le loro identità personali e
sociali diventano
funzionalmente equivalenti
e noi quanto e come ci facciamo
influenzare siamo o no anticonformisti e
su quali temi in particolare
quello che è certo è che siamo obesi a
differenza del
1950 quando la diffusione di notizie
avveniva quasi esclusivamente a mezzo
carta stampata radio e poi anche tv il
proliferare delle piattaforme social
media dei contenuti digitali ci ha resi
info obesi
l'overdose informazioni e la
sovraesposizione al flusso di notizie
sono continui e disorientanti e questo
non ci consente di distinguere la buona
dalla cattiva comunicazione
le notizie vere da quelle false
l'informazione dalla disinformazione
questo fenomeno si chiama info hdemia e
nel campo della comunicazione è la sfida
del secolo
alzi la mano chi di voi in piena
pandemia non si è fatto influenzare
arrabbiare preoccupare
inquietare almeno in un caso dal
balletto delle versioni di virologi
esperti e opinionisti sull'efficacia
vivaci né antico with e come ignorare le
notizie farneticanti sui loro effetti
bizzarri rimbalzate sui social
le statistiche parlano chiaro il 47 per
cento dei fruitori di notizie in italia
utilizza come fonte primaria di
informazione le piattaforme social
mentre il 51 e il 44 per cento
rispettivamente dei fruitori di notizie
di questa volta però a livello globale è
regolarmente esposto alle fake news a
mezzo tv o carta stampata
la cosiddetta democratizzazione dei
contenuti realizzata se con l'irruzione
dei social media ha infatti generato un
giappone che ha infettato anche i media
tradizionali quello delle fake news e
della disinformazione
la narrazione di storie la condivisione
di informazioni
appartengono da sempre alla nostra
cultura
noi amiamo ascoltare storie
tuttavia siamo nell'era della narrazione
sensazionalistica le notizie false
corrono veloci costano poco ci
coinvolgono e ci colpiscono in prima
persona perché toccano corde particolari
come emotività paura insicurezza
ecco così che la disinformazione usata
per diffondere notizie radicali zanti
creare confusione e fomentare
comportamenti che mettono a rischio la
nostra stessa sicurezza e la nostra
salute ha impatti enormi e
destabilizzanti sull'opinione pubblica e
sul comportamento delle persone
impressionante poi il dato sulla
redditività di quella che ormai è
diventata
l'industria della disinformazione
grazie alla pubblicità programmatica sui
siti web si stima infatti che chi
pubblica notizie false ricavi ogni anno
2 miliardi e 600 milioni di dollari da
inserzioni di brand e grandi marche i
quali utilizzando dei software e dei
processi automatici per la collocazione
degli spazi pubblicitari
finanziano involontariamente e
inconsapevolmente anche i siti web di
notizie false
l'opposto della disinformazione
e la comunicazione sostenibile
come deve essere la comunicazione per
dirsi sostenibile
sicuramente informazione non
sensazionalismo certo la comunicazione
sostenibile si basa su fatti e notizie
da fonti verificate è indipendente ed
etica perché trasparente ed accessibile
una comunicazione sostenibile può
supportare diverse strategie diversi
obiettivi economici politici sociali
una comunicazione sostenibile può avere
come oggetto anche la sostenibilità che
da anni ormai occupa un posto in prima
fila tra le preoccupazioni planetarie
quali sono quindi gli strumenti che i
professionisti dell'informazione hanno a
disposizione per attuare una
comunicazione sostenibile
tracciabilità applicata l'informazione è
così quello che ha deciso di fare money
puntoit la prima testata giornalistica
digitale del mondo dell'economia e della
finanza
a certificare e validare le notizie
pubblicate
tramite la piattaforma virgo che usa
tecnologia block chain
money puntoit diventa quindi un esempio
di come i professionisti della
comunicazione dell'informazione abbiano
a disposizione tecnologie e strumenti
che consentano di
certificare e validare la trasparenza
dei comfort dei contenuti verificando
nelle fonti e questo li aiuta a
contrastare il fenomeno delle fake news
ma noi lettori noi fruitori di notizie
invece come possiamo difenderci
pensiero critico
aggiornamento costante e lucidità sono
gli strumenti che ci impediranno di
cadere vittime della disinformazione
condividiamo il nostro sapere la nostra
conoscenza
mettiamo e mettiamoci in discussione
facciamo e facciamoci domande il
pensiero critico infatti ci mette in
condizione di sfidare il conformismo
rendendoci capaci di elaborare e di
prendere delle informazioni delle delle
decisioni informate elaborando le
notizie che leggiamo tutti i giorni con
lucidità
la lucidità ci mette al riparo della
dalla disinformazione aiutandoci ad
individuare la realtà dall offuscamento
la verità dalla finzione
navigando la complessità del nostro
tempo e le sue ambiguità
in un mondo alluvionato da informazioni
irrilevanti e voglio aggiungere
fuorvianti la lucidità è potere
grazie
[Applauso]